as far as i'm concerned it's total
confusion
um and it's going to cause um
a hell of a lot of disruption amongst
fans
i i don't quite understand what they
expect to get out of it
um or i mean there's enough revenue
coming in at the moment
from television riots throughout the
world to support
uh the english premier league the
bundesliga uh
the spanish league um and the champions
league and so i'm not sure
what they think they're going to get out
of this thing i'm surprised that
tottenham has put their name to it at
the moment with all the
uh the other things they've got on their
hands um i
i mean this discussions must have been
going on
quite a lot behind the scenes uh for
this thing for a while
i'm not quite sure who the authority
will be
that will be running this proposed super
league
um clearly it's not going to be uh fifa
so are they going to set up a new
authority and where will that authority
be
will it be where about whether it be
positioned
um i i think it's an idea which was once
bandished around in 1995 if i remember
riley
there was talk of a super league then
and we kind of
turned it away at the premier league we
said we're not interested because
there were a couple of clubs then who uh
were up for it but the majority of the
clubs were saying well not really
um where does that leave us
and as we saw you know as you saw
with the formation of the premier league
it seemed a huge amount of money then
revenues went up and up and up but then
of course that the players
wages did as well it just led to this
huge level of inflation i mean
would that happen again if this does fly
well look derma it's very simple
it's a very very simple equation um
there's there's talk of the founding
clubs getting an initial
payment a large sum of money what i
don't know
is where that large sum of money is
coming from
who's putting the money up to do it um
because the only way that this thing
will ever be successful
just like any other league is successful
is with companies like your own
that have funded uh television
coverage of football for many years and
your
your particular companies done a
fantastic job as we all know
this thing's only going to work if
you've got television money coming in
that's the only thing that supports a
league
in any way or form so i don't know where
the
founding fathers are going to get their
money from
i mean does anybody know where it's
coming from
well as you touch on there must be
television rights that's where they come
from for the
for the premier league at the moment and
of course uh the champions league
one imagines they they have decided
there will be a huge global bidding war
for those rights
but i mean are we just really discussing
something that's never going to happen
because we've seen that
as i mentioned the wall of criticism and
you've mentioned there i mean the
the football bodies the governing bodies
right the way up to fifa
are foursquare against it absolutely and
i hope
they stay strong and i hope that our
government
stays strong and pokes their nose in and
says stop this nonsense because
you know it's piggy in this particular
pandemic
there's not been much to look forward to
but football fans at least have been
able to watch in
using your great service um and some of
the other television channels and to get
you know and to enjoy their football
they haven't been able to go there
but to actually um you know restrict
coverage again uh if what would happen
here is some other
carrier came in and uh and and took away
the rights
but it's just not the right thing to do
and i think the fans
the fans have the power actually i think
the fans have the power and the fans
should reject this
um because you know i don't want to be
seen as an old boy uh wanting to stay
stick in the mud
and keeps a tradition but i've got to
tell you there's a lot of tradition in
football
and we should break it up now um
and whoever it is that's behind this
thing including my own club
spurs i'm absolutely amazed that they've
stuck their
their hat in the um in the ring um
um and obviously daniel was quite a
shrewd man but uh
i haven't discussed it with him but i
suppose it's one of those
one-upmanship things is that if it's
going to happen
i want to be considered as one of the
big clubs you know
i mean so you know for example what is
wolves saying what is
what is everton saying um uh what is
aston villa saying what are southampton
saying
um what is crystal palace saying you
know
what a newcastle's saying um what's a
big club define what's a big club
and why we should be included in in the
15.
and when you mention the fans do you
think i mean it's conspicuous that uh
the german teams
aren't getting involved you think we
should look the government should look
at that german model of ownership get
the fans on the board put a
lock there where the fans have the
ultimate say
um well that's news to me at them i
didn't know about the germans not
getting involved and nothing and
and good luck to them uh and
they said the german are you saying that
no german clubs have put themselves
forward
um to be a part of this elite 15 is that
what you're saying yeah because the way
they're because of the way they're
structured where
the fans have the power to 50 plus
1 lock on uh the i suppose
odd strategy in terms of what they can
do so uh with the fans against it
they're not in
yeah well that's very good and and it's
encouraging because
you know there are some great german
teams there uh
and if they're not in then it takes away
the attraction
um of of of this so-called super league
i think this is typical i with all due
respect
i say this respectfully but i think this
is very american-driven uh
by the owners of manchester united and
liverpool
um and i think they don't understand
really the culture of football in the uk
that's my
point on that i would like to make last
thought about your club um we speak on
the
very day that um they've let jose
mourinho go
yeah um i mean look you know as well as
i do
um if you've followed football as long
as i have you'll know
the writing if you say was on the wall a
little bit um
our performance at spurs has been pretty
dire
for the past few weeks we've been losing
games we've been giving away um
leads in games um and
as an ex-chairman and a follower of a
football
follower of our club i i could see that
the players in my opinion this is just
my opinion
they were not playing for him in other
words they'd lost not
they kind of must have lost respect for
him and it can happen
when um you know somebody who does a lot
of talking like he did
um and had a reputation of being
the so-called self-named um
special one um you know i i think that
the player's expectations
um kind of came to a conclusion in the
end it's not so
not so bloody special really